Oh i think if. People have no more.
Nothing more income and wanting
to live in the country
and they don't even from the start.
Won't you know think oh yes these are
the people i want to live with but just
that they all come together
if economic reasons
that it's quite stunning if they
succeed and can overcome the conflict
and find the motivation to solve problems
without i think i think we were at it
made it really easy for ourselves to have
a sort of spiritually based you know
century that we had in common.
I think
that was really important.
Well economically.
Or are not self-sustaining in any sense
and in fact from the beginning we never.
Made any claims that that's what we
wanted to do anything so we haven't had
that sort of ideal to live up to.
Economically i don't think communities are
viable the whole society works against
it and some people in fact more and
the fact that here the days are gone
when everybody was home every day doing
things on the farm because we're not any
more just about everybody's got
a job. People are studying.
Some days there would only be
a couple of people at home
and you know you could easily say i wasn't
that sad they're not together anymore
but. Again you know your needs
a new interests change and.
On most of us here at
the time and our lives
and we really want to be mixing it up in
the wider community so via i don't know
if this place is viable
but it shouldn't be by any sort of standards
you know it just it just i think works
in spite of in spite of the
forces around it somehow.
Yes absolutely absolutely.
There's some people here who never would
be on the job but most of us were.
And of course at that time
it was very easy to be.
A couple years after we were here we were
quite effective by a man named stephen
gaskin who was the leader of the farm in
tennessee and came to the nimbin area
and talked with lots of
people around and we at
that time body farm
discussed how could we.
No one share our income totally
did we want to do that
and could we create our own livelihood
so that we could get off the dole.
Some of us did my partner
and i started a business which
supported us for five years
and also employed other people
on the farm but we were never
that tight a group that we could all agree
or people were willing to put aside
their own interests and say oh yes. Ok.
Well here's an income generating thing i'm
going to forget about what i want to do
and do this that just never worked
and yeah so the welfare state of course
in many ways made this possible.
Sure.
Yeah yeah yeah well taran you create.
It was a tremendous thing for
us and lots of other people.
And i person at the time.
John see the chris is now a
globetrotter further and for us
and there's lots of other
people who have very strong.
Leanings and
that way there's two people who live here
now who work very hard for the range
first information center.
And we've supported lots of projects to
do with fighting against sand mining
and deforestation all kinds of things like
that so question it's a very
very strong value that we hold
and sometimes sometimes i think about the
wider community in general like you know
nimbin if mullumbimby everywhere
that maybe we're just pawns in
the trees hands and all that all
that really matters about what about
coming here and living in this area is
that in some way. That the trees
are got a chance to grow.
Well they're in our
possession. That's a fantasy.
I've had that if we do nothing
else. That's fantastic.
People. Yeah yeah.
Just about the whole farm ended up
down at the touraine you creat camp
and we'd already had a bit of you
know practice in organizing ourselves
and like diff some people guarding ball
who were running the first aid sort of
organisation down there and
others were under communications.
And that
that interest bit stayed very strong
several people went down to the franklin
and also took on responsible jobs in
helping that movement. Do the job.
It had to do
and then years later there was the fight
for the nightcap national for us to and.
And again i mean like there was
a big bamboo aerial pole of my
veranda c.b.
Radio going all the time from nobody listening
you know this is black stumper it is
so and so and and.
It's always been a really good feeling
for people here to get involved.
You know to lend a hand and become involved
in these things and jancee left here.
Oh about nine years ago.
That's left the farm.
But we really support what he does
and i welcome him back whenever
he comes back to australia
and he gets a lot of support moral
support from the people here
so.
Yeah well green and also other things too.
I mean there's a couple
of people like that.
I guess that we see. Spiritual inquiry.
As all all those things as
having to do with greenness
and with multiculturalism and so on.
I mean. It's not the first time but as
porton as the environmental is and is to us.
I think also the question of native
native peoples is important to us.
Education on all levels we see is part
is that people are involved in primary
and to syria dictation here
and things like we have we have two guys
here who are very very much into men.
The men's issues
and really like organizing groups of men
to talk about where their place in the
scheme of things in it is so. Yes.
Earnest our idea about what's worth well
spiritual pursuit is very very broad
i mean there's also a prison here who's
actually leading retreats now from cells so
there's the whole gamut
other people who feel
that a very good way of
inquiries to occur counselling
and run co-counsel in groups
is a which is a very gallantry
and type way of working through one's issues
which doesn't involve paying someone a
lot of money.
And we sort of keep planting trees.
Which is where that question
started is really important but.
Just it when your kids grow up and.
I guess we just see it as getting brought
you know what's important is broader
and broader all the time. We can hold.
Well it's absolutely
wonderful place. I don't.
I often wonder what the kids will
say you know when someone asks them
when they're 25 to see how they felt
about it but it's a safe place.
We've got 20 kids around 20 kids
in the place from 15 years down to
four months and.
A lot of those kids who put on up together
which i think is a wonderful thing
and will be really important will
be important in their lives.
I've always been quite amazed
that. Most of our key.
You've don't go bush actually don't
go exploring in the bush much.
I don't know why.
But they're sure have a good
time together here like
that. And. Anderson.
Anderson yeah.
Andy is i mean
and stewart spelt with a
city here i think. My name.
Stuart anderson.
And i've lived on body farm for 15 years
ever since it began father of four
children and sole parent now.
With what's a part time sole
parent with my three boys come
and go with them to weekly about
and my daughter lives in town.
And. The boys are all born here
in body farm twins born here.
14 years ago
and then the next boy 12 years old also
so i'm very much part of this place.
You know i feel a lot of affinity for
the land and the people here and i know
that i'm well. Well loved and.
I feel needed and part of the place
and that's a wonderful feeling. And.
I've done a range of things in my life.
When i first came here i was a
potter and i set up a pottery.
Here which was pretty difficult to do
when they had twins at the same time.
And in those days you know i had both.
Messages running inside of
me but to not be on the dole
and get myself established and be the
provider and also to be the new age dad
and do at least 50 per cent of the childcare
which meant that i just was running.
That's crazy. And.
New age though we considered ourselves i
don't think our communication was very
good in those in that marriage and.
And so seven years later we split up
and it was just it was pretty hard.
We weren't easy and i felt
that i think of ourselves enough time
to really enjoy each other's company
and so on.
When i go from there.
So there were quite a few things
that attracted me to body farm
and the spiritual or the inquiry into
life sort of side of it was a strong one.
I had been investigating various.
So-called spiritual avenues
and under margi's and so on
and i hadn't been particularly drawn to
any of them transcendental meditation
or whatever. And when i came of
here and met. The people and.
And talked to them about their
approach with meditation and inquiry.
I was really impressed he was a no
non-dogmatic straightforward sort of.
Practical way of sort of
gaining wisdom becoming.
Getting to know oneself and getting
to know all of life and so on.
And of course there was lots
of in those days we were.
Most people have been to india
and so there were a lot of wearing of
just sort of indian type clothes for the
women and for the men.
And using indian phrases and so on
and also it for what do you say tricky
things around enlightenment and garriott
and things like that. Which i could
take or leave i'd been to india
but not not on a spiritual quest and
more i thought more as a traveller
and just enjoying seeing the place and
and all the all the different
travellers i met. And.
So that's one thing that attracted me
was a non-dogmatic fairly practical.
Inquiry and the time put
aside for that and and
that was attractive not
only just for myself
but i also realized it had got
implications for the community it meant
that any conflict or controversy whatever
that arose was looked at in the light of
all what can we can learn from this two
people having differing opinions or
really feeling angry with each other.
Also behind them and within
the community was expected.
Of ourselves and of each
other that we we would and.
Ask ourselves how my
contributing to this conflict
or whatever it is so it was all grist for
the mill all things to learn more from.
So that was attractive. What else is
attractive about it all this bush this land.
It was originally i don't
know if you've been told.
Chosen because it had a lovely swimming
hole that's about how practical we were
that running around looking for land.
There's a lovely swing swing on this
bit of land and by that you know
and so agriculturally it's ridiculous.
And i think one of the main advantages is
that it's not directly on a on a
main road or anything like that.
And so it's very very
quiet and peaceful here.
And people have to make a bit of an effort
to come here i mean it's not a road all
the way and and while they were only half
an hour from town it just seems like.
It's not easy just to drop in
and.
You know know personally i wasn't.
I've been living on the down in a little
town called to wander which is just in
and of eden and far south
coast of new south wales.
And i really enjoyed the
village life there.
Knowing the locals and their history that
went right back and feeling excepted
and feeling like i could contribute and
that they helped me and so on and so.
One thing i regret regretted about moving
on to this community is i didn't get to
meet the local so much because we
were so busy building our houses
and getting to know each other and
something in our lovely city and so on
and me you know young babies everywhere
that i didn't get a chance to meet
the locals and i've always felt
that sort of a gap and.
It seems inevitable in
a way and and out of
that gap there's been a lot of misconceptions
about voting and what we're about
and. But. For example
the year before last.
Every year we go on
and then we spend a week together having
what we call our annual general meeting
it's a company.
Because we're a company owns the land for
us we have to have this meeting legally
but we use it as an excuse to
spend time with one another.
Talking about more long term things and
just enjoy each other's company and play
and have fun and we went to a camping
ground called would you head.
And one of us overheard some other campus
eight on campus say to another i heard
bowtie farms here but i haven't seen
anyone in robes yet you know and it's just
that. You know it's incredible.
For us and in the early days there
was also the resistance from.
We've come to be known
as as the old settlers
and there was rumor spread
about us deliberately and and.
You know that we sold babies that women
who came and really that we sold babies
and there was a price. I can't
remember how much ten thousand
or twenty thousand dollars or
something already kill us and
that no woman could come here
and leave unless she was pregnant for
some reason we never quite figured
that one out but they were all
rumors designed to put us down
and make us less acceptable or not acceptable
and that was just a small percentage.
I think of the local. Because
because having twins. Was hard.
We didn't we hadn't built a house yet
we were in a a large tent on the floor.
We had a hot water but we didn't.
It was a crazy way to have babies.
And some of the locals who
were very conservative
or really very very supportive
they let us come and
when it had been raining
for months or whatever.
We could go and wash our
nappies there and dry them
and then just help us out in whatever way
they could we stayed in there have a cup
of tea while the washing was being
done and and they were terrific
and it wasn't until the.
Tourney a creek dispute which
sort of split the community
that suddenly they turned cold and they
we just couldn't relate in the same way
and i felt really sad about
that and i imagine they did too
but at the time i just was so upset and.
Somehow in my upset i accepted that
they had to cut off from me like
that.
Well we were in reasons for coming here.
Reasons for joining this community.
I often end it. I was brought up in
canberra or in my high school years
and i often envied some couple of my younger
brothers who had gone to the school
without walls where in canberra which
had a much freer and easier atmosphere
and the students and the teachers
were more intimate with one another
that they were very friendly
gave each other hugs
and seem to have a lot of fun together
rather than just a normal straightjacket of
school and so i sort of jealous
of that scene and i came here
and i just walked into a scene like
that where people were very open
and friendly and warm to me
and invited me to converse with them
at a deeper level i suppose the normal
and that really attracted
me i felt immediately.
That i wanted to live like that
with a group of people like
that i had investigated other
communities before that
and come across one quite like that.
Yeah. Yeah. Yea.
We
and i were very idealistic in those days really
idealistic we thought we would do everything
for ourselves. That we could so
that was build our own hoses
furniture have our own births
and our own ceremonies to our own
roads. And our own income somehow.
And it was you know no one
wanted tavy on the place and.
We had this sort of creative.
Live simply so others can simply
live that was voluntary simplicity
and.
And that.
So you know i've got no one to blame
but myself in a way fit
for what we went through
but so you know trying to build a house
which wasn't a mud brick house of course
you know which you know took a lot
of work and get a pottery together
and raise young babies. Crazy way.
You know the chip heater for a bath.
So we but time was just a lot more than
turning on the tap and to find the wood
and like the five it is a damp climate
everything every day would be wet
and hard to light and so on. We made
it really hard for ourselves. And.
But the early people are came onto this
community were the pioneering time
and. Warwick not a member of this
community was only commenting to me.
I think this morning or yesterday morning
that. I think back on those days.
He wasn't there.
Just thinking about what we did you like
industry early fine im sure we had cars
and some other you know we had more
resources at our disposal but.
We really wanted to do it from the
beginning and doing it for ourselves and.
For the first couple of
years it was sort of.
Frowned upon to go out of the
community just fear itself.
If you know if you are going to go out
then you should buy food for everyone else
all the other people's needs and
so going out was a major trip.
It just meant if you. If you'd
be out all day and we just had.
We had communicators and i was along with
another man with it was a mechanic so.
We worked on the community carpool while
others were part of the roster cooking
roster because we eat together every day.
And so you know they were really sort
of heady days to remain in the working
together a lot on buildings. Feeling like
we're all contributing to the same thing.
Whatever that was we weren't quite
you know couldn't quite be named
but it was building this community
sharing our lives together.
As.
Well mine broke up but i i can't
blame just become you know setting.
Was a lot of factors.
And all of i mean terms of
partnership relationships.
And i think any survivor. But
that's not so unusual and.
In it in these times and in this
area in australia whatever.
Anyway.
It was it wasn't in terms the relationships
of people in this community.
It wasn't apparent to me
that it was a strain.
Well i think for some people who found it.
Who weren't so building oriented
because that's the way or.
They if they found that more
difficult and i know unfortunately.
Because i don't really know why
but which suddenly had a whole
lot of babies all at once.
And it meant that the sex
role division just got set.
Women had babies who were breast feeding
and so to get them involved in the building
was difficult especially because they
had to be they just didn't seem
inclined to pick it up in the same way
that the men expected of them
so. I mean this building.
We're sitting in the body farm
community center at the moment and.
I think about five or six years into our.
Since we were established i
suggested to the community
that we put aside for months.
All of us try and sort of stop
whatever work we were doing.
To work together on the community center
because at the time we were in a shack
that we called the barn
and it was really we were beginning
to get pretty shamed of it.
It was very hard to keep
clean and to function in
and it just wasn't impressive to
many of the many visitors that
that came our way we
attracted a lot of visitors
and that's another story in itself.
That was the multiple
occupancy fight and so on.
And my part of my dream in
that that i did express
but i don't think was taken on anyway.
Was that we'd work together on
that we teach each other building
and there would be any quality.
In how we'd build this building and
unfortunately i was away at the time.
Just for a month or so.
At the time that two
or three others got into designing it
and they designed this building which
is you know beautiful to look at it.
Six sided and has it has a roof with a
little pig on top and light coming in and
and the kitchen's you know spacious
with. Lots of bench space and so on.
Lots of wood and it's
high up with a good view
and if you look at it it's not an easy
building to build if you're a novice builder
every joint is an angle in it and.
And so you need an expert to
tell you what to do which meant.
Which meant
that the same old divisions of labor
sprang up people feel disempowered.
The ones that didn't know how.
Really used tools and some what used
to building felt this empowered them
and there was this energy to just get
this building built that i just couldn't.
No matter what i said.
I couldn't hold back in fact
at it and literally happened
that i said look i'm not
happy with this design
and people said no we just
want to get on with it more
or less rushed out of our little shack
and started going for it. Assessed.
I couldn't. And and you know.
Then once in the in the difficult
position of wanting something different
but not wanting to. Put it down
on everyone a damper on things.
And people didn't understand
what i was talking about.
So what was that point coming from.
People. You know yet.
Yet.
You know with the idealism in the
early days was a sort of a dogmatism.
And a sort of a control of
each other and our behavior
and we have we had a lot
of agreements for instance
and these were sort of like rules.
Although there was no sanctions.
It was just what you agreed to and
things like we had no alcohol no dope.
No dogs and cats and.
Well things that we still hold to
i we have social alcohol here now
but we also had things like not
driving on to the community
and they absolutely had to so
that would be a car free space all
around the houses which is lovely
but which meant
that some people ended up you know
we all bearing huge loads back
and forth along the road
to their place and.
You know really taking the
brunt of a decision. And.
There were there was also unspoken
agreements like for some reason in the early
days no one had a radio and.
We just sort of we will see.
No inward looking so we just wanted to
get this scene together we didn't really
want to structurally from
the outside world. I think.
And when when finally
one family wanted it.
He there was a big debate
which went on for months
and until the people wanting the t.v. Got
very frustrated. Just got one anyway.
And
that caused a fuel because some people were
varia trapped attached to the consensus
process where we all have to agree before
anything happens which is generally
wonderful and.
The consensus process i mean
is i really like it but
but it can lead to dogmatism and.
And i don't think that's healthy means
that when people feel restricted by
that sort of thing. It'll come
out sideways when some other way
or come out in the future
and some unhealthy way
that i mean this still is a little bit of
i don't know i mean some people call it
dogmatism other people would call it
common sense you know vegetarianism.
I mean that one man not
thinking very clearly
or something that's bought a little saveloy
for first they've had to the other day
and that upset
that really upset quite a few other members
because there was a vegetarian ism to
them means he's part of their
caring for life and so.
Although they weren't eating the meat they
really felt like none of us should you
know on this community
that that's what all our rules are you
know like no meat on the community.
No hope and so on and on
the community which means
that you know technically you can
go off and have your sausage
and a joint you know across the other side
of the water if you want straight back
in but it's that yeah the rules are.
There. I see is more of a.
When you say guidelines or to give
someone special from who's come.
For the place for the first time an idea
of what evaluate are they more a set of
values
but we did have we had five precepts as
well which were more buddhist in origin.
No killing no lying no
taking what is not given.
No sex that hurts others.
No intoxicants or no things that confuse
the mind and they were more guidelines
and they're speaking of our values
and and they're still there
and every one of them has been broken.
You know. So. Yet we hear them. Sure.
Exactly exactly. So i
think there's a relaxed.
Feel around those rules and agreements
these days and guidelines and so on.
They know they're not spoken of much and.
They more or less just set
the scene or something.
And these days we i mean we do have a
meditation hall on the property of it's very
rarely used. And there's no.
Schedule or anything like that.
So it's just if someone wakes up in the
morning and decides to go and meditate
and i'll go down there and
bang on the gong outside
and as an invitation for
anyone else to join them and
when i threw others my
title down. And that's it.
Or they were still involved in
running meditation retreats
and meditation still very important in
some people's lives here but not everyone.
But inquiry. Is still important.
I would say doesn't have the same
intensity that it did in the well
that idea of enquiry being important
doesn't have the same intensity as it did
but still there and i really
value that personally.